[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to GameSpot's play for
all charity livestream my name is Jake
Decker
I'm here with jean-luc psyche hello and
joining us today is a very special guest
Kyle rebel how are you doing hello I'm
doing pretty good it's kind of hot in my
room right now
so I'm gonna be screwing this game at
about 35 degrees Celsius that's right
it's for a good cause
so yeah I'm looking looking forward to
this yes so for those who don't know
Kyle is the project lead of a massive
mod called sky Bolivian which basically
is an attempt to recreate oblivion in
well not necessarily in Skyrim but with
Bulls he's been working on this mod for
a very long time
and we're excited to check it out I'm so
excited I'm glad I hope everything will
go according to plan I did make a
promise to myself that I would donate
$10 for every crash we get it's one
thing this is this is made by volunteers
it's there there will be bugs that we'll
run into but it doesn't represent the
final build mmm but yeah definitely if
this interests you at all I think you're
gonna really enjoy a stream because this
is some cool stuff yeah it'll be good
actually before we start I'd do want to
thank everyone from GameSpot really
quickly for this opportunity I think
it's really cool that through this
project were able to do some good I will
say it's it's a little overwhelming to
be amongst guests such as Daniel door
Jake Bell Dino and Troy Baker just some
of the names I've seen pop up during the
stream but I'm really thankful for the
opportunity and I hope your viewers at
my own will enjoy this little little
charity event we put together
yeah I'm excited absolutely thank you
all right load in get us started yeah
man what we go also if you're in chat um
feel free to drop questions for Kyle and
we'll get those to him right away and if
you do want to donate as well you can
find the links at bitly / GS - BLM
Orbitz dot Li / - yes - CO vid but all
the support helps ya and if you happen
to be watching on my own twitch channel
if you type exclamation point charity
you will find these links that were just
mentioned as well cool more setup than
we are all right can you guys see the
game yeah I can see it it looks like
you've just exited the sewers exactly we
got a way better Armour set than you
would if you just cheated a little bit
I'm completely decked out my inventory
is full but yeah these are the sewers
that you acts at the game from this is
the the tutorial level pretty much
behind this door and this is the first a
lead rune you will actually come across
in the game it's called over'n it's a
really nice place to check out low level
there should be two bandits behind the
walls I have a nice oh yeah you and me
both give me both places sorry oh sorry
I interrupt you I was just saying it's
such a good starter dungeon and it has
so much stuff in it oh yeah and I think
it really shows kind of like the power
of this project there's this this first
scene did this first image if you if you
laid right next to your oblivion
screenshot it it just it kind of goes to
show on what you can do with you know
the newer technology newer engine and
some really good 3d artists
yes so how how big is the the sky
Bolivian team because it's a team of
volunteers but it's not like a
traditional obviously it's not like a
traditional game studio because a you
guys are already working remote no
matter what because the team is from all
over the place and then yeah also this
is this is this mod is entirely free
well not entirely free right you need to
own both Skyrim in oblivion in order to
download this mod win it yeah I think
our team is it's it's not that big
actually especially when I look at other
modding projects that the team is it's
pretty small I think in total there
there are about a hundred members on a
team but if we count active members like
people that contribute once a month I
think you are down to about thirty so
yeah but I mean it it's it's a really
tight-knit group of very like-minded
nerds so it's it's it's a fun time we
have we have a lot of fun working on
this mod and yeah it's it's it's it's
good you know I don't think science
matters per se I mean sometimes it does
I think we have a pretty good flow going
so I mean yeah it's it we're in a pretty
good spot right now as far as the size
of the team goes but I will say that if
there's people listening right now who
are experienced in you know 3d modeling
or have experienced modding Skyrim we
can definitely use your help okay this
is actually kind of funny I am I kind of
cheated just before the stream started
and I leveled my character way up and
something I noticed right away is that
the bandit is wearing myth full armor
thing at least that's something we want
to get rid of down the line because I
think the the level scaling and oblivion
was kind of ridiculous it's it's cool
that we remade it so far but
you know fighting bandits in the the top
tier armor sets it's not really you know
balance in my opinion but yeah it makes
for a nice challenge I guess do you do
you mind equipping a torch maybe oh yeah
definitely
yeah the the lighting for the ayleid
dungeons has been remade to be a bit
more eerie and dark totally I definitely
prefer that but I just want to make sure
I can see something I can I can imagine
it's it's hard for the people watching
hmm so I imagine most of the people on
the developer team are probably like
John Luke and I and that we're like yeah
Skyrim is pretty cool but oblivion was
where it's at oh no that's how I feel I
don't know why I always think about is
that just me because it was my first one
I don't know I think about I definitely
agree with you to be honest and I just
got totally annihilated and I think I'm
gonna go back to I actually made two
saves one that's level one and one
that's the total beefcake I'm not gonna
survive on the second now what I agree I
think oblivion had had such a better
story and atmosphere compared to scram I
mean I love I love both games a lot for
their own things but I know just
Oblivion it's it's something else
someone in the chat is asking is
wondering if you're either team have
tried Skyrim VR at all I mean there
aren't many modders who can afford a VR
had said I think one guy on our team
actually bought one recently I know I
myself don't have one so I wouldn't I
wouldn't know if it works it should in
theory yeah I'd be interesting alright
those bandits look more like bandits
yeah yeah another question are you guys
remaking the DLC as well so I think that
talking about Shivering Isles I'm sure
that's it's a good question the the
smaller DLC we plan to include in in the
mod but the bigger one like Shivering
Isles it's it's too much work I mean we
could but we'd rather get the main mod
like the main game outs ASAP and then
focus on the DLC after totally and I
mean yeah it's just like I mean you can
only do this for so long you know I've
been doing this since 2013
that's when kind of the whole planning
stage began and then most of the people
work on the project now or from 2016 or
more recent and as much fun as it has
been to do this I would like to get it
just done at some point and nodes right
away just isn't really an option yeah
makes sense okay you got another
question this was from Daniel Moreno
who's uh who's a good dude but he asked
how did you achieve a consistent vision
between several 3d artists did you use
style this is something that I remember
asking you to because that always seems
like it would be a very difficult thing
to do yeah
well when it comes to to 3d artists or
you know concept artists for that matter
I try to work very closely together with
them throughout the process um to ensure
that yeah the the quality and the style
remains consistent it's it's definitely
not an easy job but it's it's just a
whole lot of communication um to make
sure that you know you achieve somewhat
similar and result that makes sense yeah
totally I have the kind of answers your
question I mean there's not like a
really specific answer to the question
we just we go over it together and
we tried to come up with with something
that that fits oblivion and that fits
asses that been made already so it all
kind of works together nicely
no nice you've definitely protected the
the finishers in this game like every
kill I see it which is something that
didn't happen much for me in Skyrim
unless you get one of those mods that
just makes it happen all the time and I
love them what actually it's a cool mod
a lot of cool mods out there do you have
like a favorite Skyrim mod or like a
couple Skyrim mods that you oh
definitely yeah this game without Skyrim
without I think any go is probably my
favorite follower mod and I'm pretty
sure I saw the creator of any go on
twitch on my own twitch just now so a
little shout out for him other than that
the the unofficial patches you know
because you know as much as we love the
pathetic games they are buggy as health
oh yeah that is like required
downloading yeah let's see other than
that I really like there's a there's a
couple of really cool perk mods that
make the perks a bit more interesting
can scare them they their kid they're
not bad that they're pretty simplistic
though and I like getting a few perk
mods to remedy that yeah definitely I'm
I'm the same way like I I'm definitely
looking at the perk mods when I start a
new Skyrim playthrough although usually
when I start a new Skyrim playthrough I
download a bunch of mods start it up
play an hour and I'm like yeah that's
all I got time for it and then I don't
go back to it yeah also I mean we at the
beginning of the stream we talked about
bugs and I'm not gonna pretend like the
sky blurriness is super close to being
finished and there's no bugs left as you
can see that the door is broken
well Constanza broken right right we
have
[Music]
these these pressure plates which you
need to activate to open the door and
they work which is great but you can
hear the audio is looping right now oh
really which is also yeah a little bug
so you just open card nothing to hide
but we are making good progress I don't
think I'm actually gonna finish the
entire dungeon because most of the
beauty in Seattle is definitely outside
I'm not so much inside you know I think
that's liked about oblivion is there's
something about walking like just
walking from town to town like I know
that game lets the game lets you fast
travel like immediately but like I I
love just walking between the different
towns and seeing like the the landscape
change and the trees change dad yeah we
got another question here from Chris
Christopher dinosaur games so what is
the biggest challenge
other than coordination of getting all
the people to work on this project so I
guess apart from coordination what is a
big challenge that that you that you've
run into doing this I mean to be honest
coordination is probably the hardest one
that that's kind of like my main job for
the project this is make sure everything
is coordinated properly but besides that
it's I mean quest implementation is is
quite difficult it's it's it requires a
lot of people who can do things that I
don't understand let's be like that I
have no idea how they do it I just I
just listen and make sure they have what
they need
so the question Department is definitely
something that's that's that's a lot of
tons of people that do things that not a
whole lot of us can do and the
difficulty with that is finding people
who are able to do that
so yeah I think that the project
requires some very specific skills that
are pretty hard to come by you know when
you're a game studio offering you know
an actual job in payments and that's
even harder I feel like when all you can
offer is you know your name in the
credits right I think that's that's a
pretty difficult part of the project
other than that you know because
everyone is a volunteer it can be
difficult sometimes to keep people
motivated so what I try to do personally
is I'm in the voice yet every single day
after work or now that I'm work from
home sometimes during work you know make
sure that you keep communicating with
everyone learn people's first names it's
kind of like little things to make the
project look more personal it's pretty
difficult you know syncing all that time
it's in the to creating those
relationships with people to follow up
on that years of candy who sounds like
he's or this person is part of the team
says do be aware that Kyle whips us
recklessly to keep up morale
I used from the landscaping department
that's gonna like a running joke in a
team I'm really nice to everyone don't
worry I'll get that mud crab yeah
Sierra's there I think this is I have a
question for Kyle will features of
Skyrim still work in the sky Bolivian
game so if I want to play through the
sky if I want to play through this is a
vampire Lord will I be able to do that
[Music]
well the thing is like vampirism what's
a thing in Oblivion it just worked very
different from the way it did in in
Skyrim I preferred how it works in this
game I think
I think both both are pretty cool in
their own way it's hard to say right now
it's it's something that I haven't
tested I I don't see why not but I I
don't dare you know confirm with the
night yeah totally
right right by the way you'll you'll see
some unnamed objectives pop up on my
screen every now and again that's for
quests that have specific triggers like
we just started the Nirnroot quest
seeking routes but the the quest like
the objectives for the quest have not
been written okay so instead of you know
visit X mage in X town it just says
complete objective 9 if you were
wondering why the days there you go oh
wow this looks great
yes this is probably one of my favorite
areas in the map simply because well I
mean you're right around T Barrow City
this is still pretty civilized as well
so there's a lot of settlements nice
dense forests mm-hmm and just beautiful
vistas everywhere but I can actually do
real quick is give you guys a bit of an
aerial view since the weather's pretty
pleased you can see pretty far out
so this is this is the area where we're
at right now the area around the city
that's called the heartland it's is
fairly green lush a lot of grass fields
and not too densely forested behind we
have Skyrim you can see the snowy
mountain tops and the general mountains
which see Rideau and Skyrim both share a
border with we have the great forests
which is an ancient forest near coral it
also has the the settlement of hectored
which some I believe you fully remember
shady [ __ ] goes down there hmm we have
all the way in the distance you can't
really see it all too well but we have
black wood which is an actual flat swamp
now which is pretty know which I think
it might be one of my favourite areas
purely because it's an actual super
murky swamp where isn't it Bolivian it
it was you know it was randomly
generated terrain and it wasn't anything
right that's awesome yeah I was gonna
ask if you guys were like changed
anything dramatically to sort of like
give it a more distinct style I was
thinking about like oh yeah Bruma how
you know it borders a skyrim and like
when they made a Bolivian they didn't
really have like that Skyrim aesthetic
like kind of created like did you guys
kind of add some of that Skyrim
aesthetic back into oblivion in like
areas like Burma yeah yeah definitely
so actually we tackled all the different
regions which is one of the the main
reasons why I find serials so so cool is
you had these different biomes in one
map you at the Heartland switch were
right now you have the general mountains
the vales Mountains the Gold Coast
cloven Highlands and the West world I
think that's all of them
and every region
at least in in the lore is supposed to
be very distinct from one another in
oblivion it wasn't that much different
but we're definitely trying to to
improve the way every region feels and
looks and also sounds by you know
changing the sound design different
different sound effects that kind of
stuff yeah so we're definitely trying
our best to make the the world look as
as unique and as interesting as possible
and really reward players for exploring
there's lots of hidden loot and
treasures and cool stuff to be found one
of my favorite areas that that I saw was
was I think it's Blackwood right like
cuz it's originally it was like supposed
to be the swampy area but in Oblivion
it's just kind of like there are more
trees here but but yeah the screenshots
and video that I've seen of what you
guys have done with Blackwood is is is
awesome like it looks so cool yeah
definitely in Oblivion because of the
the randomly generated terrain it was a
lot of hills and like you said a ton of
trees and not that much that I don't
even think there were a lot of puddles
or collections of water anywhere yeah
and with our black woods we kind of
doubled down on what we think like what
would or should look like
we just flattened the entire place and
you know remade it from scratch you can
also see this ugly area that I'm walking
through right now that's not the level
of quality we're going for per se but
it's in between two claims so someone's
working on the area above and someone's
working area below and we we always keep
it a strip kind of empty so that when we
merge plugins which is how we update our
internal build we don't get conflicts
because if people work on the same spot
and you try to merge those plugins the
the software that we use you know just
kind of goes bananas doesn't like it at
all
interesting it's it's pretty neat to
like see more of the development side
like I resuming out and showing how
claims work and whatnot because it's
like myself included and I'm sure a lot
of people in the chat like even though
this is a mod that's a side of like game
development and design that almost never
even seen yeah and that's actually why
we're trying to work on on a video
series to kind of take people behind the
scenes and really discuss in length how
how things work on this team how um you
know areas get created how 3d assets go
from concept to 3d to be implementing
game let's watch that and it's the site
of game developer really see but I think
it's one of the most interesting things
you know fans could could you know get a
glimpse of so we got a lot of questions
here oh go ahead okay I'm gonna read off
some questions we've got a got a meme
question here but I want to read it
anyway this is from saying ten day he
says well horse armor be in this game
and how much will it cost its we have
someone on the team who wanted to do it
for fun we have we have some really cool
armors and that's the thing you know
this is volunteer work so when when
people they work on tasks that need to
be done and they work on tasks that they
want to do and someone really wants to
do horse armor just for the fun of it
and he created some really cool designs
and they're actually done another
in-game right now but yeah look like sky
bolivian it'll be free but the quality
of it is really good and besides being
kind of like a running joke now I think
it really does add a little something to
have a fully plated horse by your side
kicking goblins and whatnot okay we got
we got more questions here I'm going to
go through do you intend to change or
Quest's in mechanic's that's kind of a
big question I guess we can start with
quests like did you plan on changing
around quest much or are they gonna be
very similar to what people remember
West's not so much we're currently in
the the implementation process for
quests and we kind of want to keep them
as close to oblivion as possible I mean
Oblivion's writing is phenomenal it's
it's the best writing I've ever seen in
any other schools game if I'm being
fully honest so there's there's nothing
I would change about quests or writing
in general mechanics yeah I think
there's gonna be some mechanics that
will be improved upon or quote-unquote
modernized a little but in the end like
with quests it's our it's our goal to
remake or reinvasion something so we
don't stray too far off what made
something good or wonky in Oblivion but
France is a skill like athletics
you know which allows you to jump 40
feet in the air and just run around like
you were jacked up on whatever on skooma
that's something that unfortunately we
won't be able to bring back in the game
hmm
question for Kyle how are the loading
screens coming on I heard they were
being worked on a while back yeah we
actually we finished all the loading
screens last week we've had a fantastic
concept artist by the name of fury on
from Russia who completed all 62 loading
screens in 82 days oh and about hours
that was over the last two three months
that's when he joined the project so
it's it's coming it's it's fantastic and
they look amazing
they they just have not been implemented
yet you can see that our UI is some
parts are implemented others aren't for
instance all the the button arts and you
can have under your keyboard or
controller have an implemented but
some reason we didn't do skills map
magic or the main HUD right so you know
we don't have a priorities exactly
straight I don't think but um it'll
it'll happen slowly but steadily see
other questions do we have here actually
before we move on to next question the
the town we were just at right over
there on the mountain peak is where
we're gonna be walking through a quest
for you guys that we implement it I was
just kind of waiting for the chats on or
the the streams on YouTube and twitch to
you to pick up so that people don't miss
it okay just remind me to go back there
in about I don't know 20 30 minutes okay
I mean sigh my gosh I mean there's
plenty of stuff to show you guys but I
don't think we're in that much of a
hurry yes no no fantastic and just a
reminder for everyone watching that this
is also a charity stream we are donating
both to Kova direct relief for those
people on the front lines as well as
black lives matter we have links for
both of those right here as well as in
the description so please go check those
out and donate if you can to help those
out and we'll be donating if the game
crashes at all yeah be $30 per crash yes
yeah by any chance you're getting
donations yet because we did prepare a
little something for for the the stream
I think either way I'm gonna just just
do it but there's any if there's any big
donation I can give a shout out that
would be great even better yeah so if
you guys want a special surprise as well
go ahead and donate we're also we should
mention that we're doing this for this
is week what four of six so throughout
the next couple weeks we're gonna have a
bunch of cool guests a bunch of cool
segments every day so make sure to
tune in and of course would be raising
money during all that as well
so oh what's going on okay so that's so
cool how's the magic spelling for you I
mean before I forget and just don't
don't use the spell at all I mean it's
it's something stupid but one of our
guys worked on that for like a day I
think thing I love that it's awesome
yeah I think we're gonna make our way
into the ancient forests of well the
great forests is what it's called cool
it's a pretty pretty epic location
against oblivion and again it's
completely different from what it wasn't
oblivion but I don't think that's a bad
thing per se now I like to see the
difference definitely I definitely love
this area there's just something about
like seeing the Imperial what is it the
Imperial Citadel Oh
SuperSpeed yeah just from like all
corners of the map it doesn't it just
really like I don't know sets the tone
really does or the mood I guess Nick the
mage as how long has this project been
in development and when did you have the
idea to make this project so I it wasn't
it wasn't my idea I joined in let's see
I think in in 2013 so the way the
project started it was kind of like a
experiments for two guys who created the
tool that would convert Oblivion's data
files to Skyrim and I can I just
stumbled upon it randomly and okay this
this could actually be something like it
can be something besides just the cool
little experiments and for the next two
years I focused on kind of organizing
the project as we know it right now
seeing what it would take to to start
yes like you're your own little indie
studio but with no budget what that
would take
and you know just kind of planning and
and and seeing where where things would
go in and I think 2016
I made our first video which I think was
called Skye Bolivian familiar faces
which is when we had the the NPC's
finished for all the difference
living characters in game and that's
kind of where it where the whole thing
started and about Illyria
yeah a year later we had our first
stable build which we could you know
make environments like this on and I
made another video and that got like a
million views and that's when things
really started picking up and from there
like 2016 the the project kind of really
started anything before that was pretty
minor work and mostly like planning and
you know 2016 was was kind of bananas
it's when we got a lot of new volunteers
I had to suddenly manage 3d departments
a concept departments landscaping
departments make sure everything ran
smoothly and from there it only got
bigger and better well we actually have
a bunch of donations and start reading
off they've been starting to pour in we
have four Co vid Direct Relief we have
$10 from anonymous we have $20 from
Jason dovey and we have $10 from Amanda
so shout-out you you thank ya thank you
so much
and then for black lives matter
donations we have $25 from our very own
Erte who runs the stream in the back
right now thank you Eric and then we
also have $10 from Nawaz oh man he was
on that other stream that we were on
with Danny had a yeah Iqbal I think
that's how you say his last name I hope
I got that right this time helps me out
he donated $10 so thank you shout out to
you as well
man these trees look so good it's cool
how very different the mood of this area
feels compared to other parts of the map
because like I was saying before in in
the original oblivion all of it was just
kind of like very bright and green which
I loved but like it's cool to go in this
forest that's kind of got like maybe not
a moody or look to it but like a darker
yeah this story actually behind this
thing this is an ancient an ancient
forest that's split up into two parts
you have the redwoods and the agent oak
forest I really wanted to make this area
feel bits
what's the word like it's it's kind of
claustrophobic to walk through because
it's very hard to see anything through
the trees and it's very hard to find
your way like I I mean I've been through
is for it's like a hundred times but I
lost the path which is why you saw me
stumble around for a few minutes right
there but but I found the beaten path
yeah we get back but it's definitely
it's a lot different from from our other
regions yes yes a lot more just it feels
a little secluded as well yeah this is
another key question but still a blue
jet one not locked
live wants to know well the NPC's look
normal or is that an impossible task it
depends on your definition of normal if
you think species look remotely normal
then yeah the they will look normal ish
for sure
i-i-i have a love for oblivion NPCs I
mean I I certainly wouldn't expect that
to be how characters look by today's
standards but I don't know there's
something about them that I just find
charming I think I think part of it for
me too is is like the way they look when
you mix with the voice acting and how
like every race has one voice actor or
every s-21 one freaks gender yeah I'm
like it's just and how sometimes online
mixed up so like it's the same voice
actor but they're doing a different
voice like The Beggar's oh my god I love
that stuff a coin for an old beggar
thank you kind sir it's like oh my gosh
Wow is dark um
one interesting thing you mentioned
about quests I remember is is voice
acting right like you you guys are you
can basically plug in the original voice
acting oh we just got another big
donation I think we did we got um well
we got three donations for direct relief
Moondoggie donated $10 smart blue cat
donated $15 and Mitchell Morris donated
$50 to pain relief so smart blue cat is
actually the author of any go believe in
gay we go up on boys this is the
Oblivion gates some people may have seen
in the trailer he posted last summer
this was the one not as cool as or as
recognizable as the one in kvetch but
still pretty nice right is it does it
still work where the sky changes over
time yes but it's not this one oh it's
just a fun plug and I still have enabled
her actually maybe this guy's alright
it is oh there we go it's because I was
messing around with the weather's just
now yeah oh there's a little text look
yeah this like nice stuff flow around
cool I was gonna work on what yeah I
always thought these were so cool just
randomly popping up we have a really
good weather artist goes by the name of
stayed and he made this fantastic
weather variant for the the Bolivian
gays you can see the the embers and
smokes flying around it adds so much I
think it's really cool yeah it looks
great yeah
but actually I kind of want to move out
of the great forest if you guys don't
mind and go maybe towards the Gold Coast
which is maybe one of my favorite areas
in the game yeah go he for you again
gives people a quick look at the map as
well
oh man fact is that oblivion like Serie
dough is a lot bigger than Skyrim I mean
scare Musa is a huge map already I
remember I send you a comparison picture
Jake exact numbers of how much bigger
co2 is compared to Skyrim but yeah we
definitely have our work cut out for us
like there's a lot more to do with with
the world map compared to you with
Skyrim just gonna that that's pretty
good oh that looks incredible I think
anvil is probably one of my favorite
towns in the game yeah for me too I
think
and actually with with Skype Livi and
something really cool that we did is we
have you have you ever seen the concept
art for anvil from oblivion it was a
really cool art for it that was never
used either
time limitations or I don't know what
happened maybe the engine couldn't
handle it maybe it was too big for
consoles but we use that concept to kind
of remake anvil oh okay
so it's a lot bigger it has a really
cool waterway as well
oh that's awesome
an oblivion it's kind of like it just
around a shape like that yeah that
sounds right and of course the widow
changes directly but yeah I remember
spending so much time in anvil just like
I don't know like not even doing quests
just walking around talking to NPCs and
like I remember that quest to get the
house that guy sells you a house for
5000 gold and I just remember thinking
that was like the coolest quest that's
the thing I think anvil has some of the
best quests in the game yeah there's
some really cool ones and you have the
the one with the women in the in who are
kind of scamming men yep that one's
really good when it's super well-written
really loved it I think a key question
the the Dark Brotherhood Guild takes
place in anvil in the lighthouse if I
remember yeah a couple people who noting
how much the lighting has improved
because lighting looks great like I love
this like warm sort of glow oh we got
another donation I just thought go up Oh
oh my gosh yes we do uh Daniel K Z
donated $100 to uh Kobe relief with a
message that says I do not have any game
making skills however I will give you
whatever I can muster I would love to
play sky Bolivian before too long you
guys have my prayers and donations to
help it belong awesome and that one's
for you
[Laughter]
we also have $10 for black lives matter
from Nikko ku ku ku I think is how I say
that so shout-out to you as well for
donating for black lives matter this is
a this is really small
but I love the ther waves yes yeah the
water looks great and also the the
beaches are kind of like flat in
Oblivion they would go from like small
hum still like directly sink right into
the sea yeah you ever noticed that but
it was it was yeah just like immediately
just diver it off ya know it's like a
gentle slope it's it's very small and
most people won't notice or care and
what I personally like a lot well so you
can hear in the background right now one
of the new songs like the ambient music
this one is specifically written for the
Gold Coast
which I really love our new soundtrack
it's really good mmm
it doesn't replace Oblivion's but it
just kind of complements it like every
region in serial now has their own
soundtrack to boot yeah we're asking
about the music if if that's like a do
you have any of the original tracks in
here is that like a licensing thing or
it's actually in one of the more recent
Skyrim creation Club updates they added
the oblivion soundtrack to the files
I'll just wait for because we can just
use them without you know any yeah I
also apologize for the people watching
on my own twitch that I'm not answering
questions but I can only do so much at
the same time we can try and keep an eye
on that chat as well yeah I'll open it
up I've got you youtube open is oh wait
I don't think I can open multiple chats
on well that's just check it every now
and then gamer wants to know does the
Nibin a river area represent ELLs wire
next
the border yeah kinda we have so what we
have for all the different conjoining
regions or provinces we have border
gates
mm-hmm so I mean you can't go to
elsewhere to to Black Marsh or any of
those provinces but there's there's
border gates and sometimes there's like
landmarks behind them to kind of
resemble in a way the the place that
they're they're right next to that make
sense yeah that makes sense
your money or your life oh no I get the
[Laughter]
crushing with the text yeah I was
actually gonna ask if you guys ever win
when like kind of looking for
inspirations for some of the the
aesthetics of the other areas do you
guys ever look at like the Elder Scrolls
online because they've been like adding
all the different regions like slowly
over time in that game like have you
guys looked at that game just for like
inspiration not much I mean year--so is
is a completely different beast it is we
kind of look at or me personally I what
I did for all the the regions of
Cyrodiil is I just dove into the lore
books that are found in all the games
and kind of wrote how I envisioned it
would look right and I would get a
concept artist to what to kind of sketch
a few ideas out and then from that we
would get her some real life references
to Boone and slowly would say that you
would get like a a mood board full of
like custom and just stuff that we found
online that we thought would resonate
with the areas in question
we don't really use you so I mean ESO is
gold coast is pretty good but other than
that I wouldn't personally use any of
that as a reference right it is pretty
different I would say kind of like the
design they're going for yeah it's not
better though and especially their gold
cause I think it's pretty good they're
more or less the same idea that we have
which is kind of like a warm military
Mediterranean mm-hmm
look and feel a couple people across the
chat's have been wondering how
lock-picking is gonna work in this game
is it going to be
Skyrim lock-picking system or Oblivion's
yeah so good or bad news depending on
which one you like better it's not gonna
be like oblivion so I'm hoping that will
make a few people happy and I'm pretty
sure it'll make a few people sad I'm I
personally loved oblivious lock-picking
because I was really good at it and
nobody I knew understood it once you get
it I mean you're you're good yeah got it
and yeah made me feel pretty good about
myself sometimes
I remember cuz you could technically you
could lock pick a a very hard lock right
off the bat and like even if you didn't
have a lot of lock picks you just say
yeah we have another $10 donation from
sky-blue Ian Toby relief as well as
Brandon Davis who donated $25 for black
lives matter
so shout out to both of you thank you
also the donations
Toby is actually one of her 3d artists
who is working on the steel weapon sets
right now actually talking about weapons
and armor I haven't showed you guys any
of it so far and I have like did this
character he doesn't look like you know
he's carrying around like complete
weapon sets but he is so you should
really quickly this is a really cool one
it's the the arena armor oh nice
is this the yeah you Europe originally
you're part of team blue but I have two
yellow one for some reason so don't hate
me for it just gonna have to deal with
it see some other cool ones yeah the the
the Dwarven arm was finished recently oh
it's so cool we use a pseudo PPR
workflow to to make the textures really
pop which is why you know if you put
this next to Skyrim there's just you
know there's no doubt about which which
one looks better and it's like it looks
actually metallic which is really cool
I'm very happy that we found out how to
do this
it's it's a little complicated but it's
it really pays off I think you know if
you look at the shield if you look at
the shine how bad it will be compressed
but um I can see that looks pretty good
both the evany arm I'm wearing right now
and the the Dwarven armor were made by
sparrows who is a 3d artist of ours I
love that Bini armor every armor in
glass armor yeah I always thought glass
armor was really cool and yeah
evany armor to glass someone's really
cool doesn't make sense practically
though the idea of wearing yes in fact
you know glass armor shattered while you
were wearing it that would probably hurt
a lot I'm sure there's no reason though
it's not actually glass yeah it's all
glass but it's it's not avoid cinema
taxes the ebony armor looks [ __ ] sick
thanks we try to make we have different
tiers for armor obviously but the the
ebony armor since it's like top tier we
really wanted to make it [ __ ] badass
like you you you just need to feel like
a badass [ __ ] wearing that
basically which I think we we nailed it
looks like a proper Knight
probably maybe on steroids or something
it just looks [ __ ] awesome which is
exactly is that a farmer yeah this is
the the shrouded armor
we have a black variation as well
there's actually a small bug with the
textures like it looks kind of plasticky
so we have to reconvert those okay but
it shouldn't be a huge deal I don't feel
like wearing the the Dwarven armor
though I think it's just the most one of
the most badass armor sets we have in
game right now yeah and four unique
weapons I'm not sure like people
probably have requests and unique
weapons they want to see from oblivion
I'm just gonna go through a few really
quickly yeah one thing you mentioned
like in Oblivion a lot of the unique
weapons are just like it's steel swords
but they glow a different color because
they have an ability but you were saying
that many of those unique or I don't
know how many but some of the unique
weapons you guys have actually gone
through and recreated like a big one
that comes to mind is I think it's
called the shimmer strike right yeah
yeah is it is a dagger from the the
arena questline usually couldn't pick
anything up but it I felt like the the
arena announcer tells you specifically
about this blade that they will wield
and I felt like if you're gonna name the
the dagger by it you know if you're
gonna give it a name gonna go to all the
trouble to do like adding that little
detailing game it should look unique as
well I think it was an elven dagger or
maybe glass I'm not quite sure but we
made a unique model for it and we made
it so you can pick it up throughout the
quest line so you like keep it with you
as kind of like a Oh a keepsake a reward
for yeah yeah that's pretty cool because
that is one thing like that you'd get
all these weapons that would sounds so
cool like it
pick it up you would just be like okay -
it's just that it's one of the other
ones but it's got a green tint to it or
whatever yeah yeah and this is kinda
disappointing in Skyrim as well in a lot
of case like they didn't really change
that too much for instance if you you
know finished the the the first part of
the main quest where you have to help
Whiterun you know with the dragon attack
at some point that you all will say like
thank you so much for helping us and
here's like a weapon for my personal
armory and it's it's just a regular
steel sword or a regular shield and it's
like you know really you know gone
alcoholic robot in the chat is is he's
appalled that yours that you're stealing
weapons in the arena it's only that one
weapon it's only the one I promise
go ahead I was gonna ask if how you guys
are handling like enemy variety cuz
because in the original oblivion like
the the sort of like enemies that would
populate the world were dependent on
your level which was kind of weird it's
like I remember the first time I played
it I didn't really play it right so like
I wasn't leveling up that much so I
actually beat the game and I barely saw
any of like the really high level
enemies because I was like I just wasn't
playing it correctly like I wasn't
properly like using the correct skills
to level up and I know Skyrim kind of
changed that if you guys sort of
adjusted any of that especially since
you're like incorporating Skyrim some of
Skyrim systems at this point in
development not yet that's definitely on
on the table or well I should say that
that's how we want to do it like you saw
at the beginning of the stream I had a
level 30 plus character and I walked
into the first a laruen and you know the
guy was wearing mithwa armor right um we
don't we don't want that in the in the
finalized product so we want we want
bandits to always you know look like
bandits and be kind of easy to defeat
higher tier enemies will definitely
spawn but they won't spawn the oak on
the main road for instance to mow you
down we're level two but they'll be
guarding like higher tier oblivion gates
or more interesting dungeons so there
will definitely be a level of
grind to some extent like it won't lock
you out of any part of the the main game
but you know if you want to explore
every single cave and every single
dungeon you will have to sometimes level
up and come back after you licked your
wounds okay cool because hopefully you
will get your ass kicked at least you
know a couple of times we've got another
question from for you soon which I think
should be interesting do you plan on
sorry do you plan on doing the same
thing as the people remaking new vegas
and fallout 4 where they're releasing
some of the content they've finished for
everyone to download or are you waiting
until it's done I guess just to clarify
like are you waiting until this game is
content complete before you release it
or do you plan on like because I think
I've seen you tweet and talk about
before like once this game is like when
it does come out or when you guys that
not everything will be in there yet like
you might add some stuff later so I was
curious about the plan there I know that
still a ways out well I think what both
are asking is if we're maybe doing
separate mod releases I know that's
something that's followed new vegas o
team does and we have released our steel
armor for instance and we want to
release more but it's it's kind of it's
pretty low priority
so yeah ahead of release we will
definitely you know provide the
community with some cool weapons and
armor sets but it's kind of like TBD on
when if and how we're going to go about
doing that at this point because the the
main like that the first release will it
needs to be feature complete like we
can't leave out half the armor sets for
instance
yeah or have any other creatures at
least that's how I feel about it so
that's that's everything is going to be
part of the main release what we will
release after is you know smaller DLC or
small content add-ons fixes that kind of
thing okay
cool question for each of you
what's your favorite quest from oblivion
mine is the collection estai don't
remember which one the collection astiz
but one of my favorite ones is the is
the when you go to that party and
they're trying to solve the murder and
good
I got a step away for just one second
I'll be back quickly yeah that's
definitely one of my favorites I like
some of the early ones a lot I like I
like the one with the the like I said I
like a lot of the anvil ones the house
one is great the the the one with the
like use of the wint the women who are
like stealing men's possessions it's
pretty good the all the one the one in
coral where you go to that like creepy
town where they're like kidnapping -
yeah edgert yes that one is fantastic I
remember that was like one of the early
ones I did where I was like oh my god
like this is crazy she do that quest yes
I'm just quickly going to show you
kovash and then move on okay that's good
we also have two more donations for Koba
direct relief one from sky-blue v&d who
donated $10 oh cool and another one from
Sky Blu being sky I think Skywalker here
we go
the name was cut off for a sec Skye
Bolivian Skywalker who donated $10 as
well so thank you to both of you
stand back civilian this is no place for
you get back to the encampment at once
it took a while to trigger because I
I've I've been messing with the weather
so if you put the weather's too to
change at a rate of two instead of the
regular I think twenty whatever it is it
just takes like literally five minutes
for it to turn still wearing the armor
from oblivion which we just born
directly as a placeholder we have some
work all the regard specific armor says
right now and the first three are pretty
close being complete and since they're
modular you know the rest should be done
by this summer hopefully it's really
looking forward to having that in game
playing this area for the first time in
doing the fight inside capatch and
thinking it was so epic and then
replaying oblivion about a year or two
ago and being like yeah not as exciting
as I remember it's yeah what they do
with it is still so cool though I think
I just like that buildup of like
thinking like oh go to this town next
and then like realizing like they it's
completely destroyed it was just like so
cool it's like very it's a good way to
set the stakes early on where you're
like oh [ __ ] they destroyed an entire
town like this is a town I could have
like been in to me people take quests
and like because of what's happening
this town just got leveled alright I
think is a neat introduction to the
story of the game yeah oh no we took the
weathers with us
oh yeah like we like take a second if
you were okay so this is like the the
quest we we implemented this week to
kind of give you guys an idea
oh no okay I may have to reload a save
file give me a second okay okay this is
a interesting bug I think because we
waited like literal days in game by keep
using or spamming their commands to make
time pass faster the the invincibility
invisibility effect wore off which is
why you could see people actually
running around which is not supposed to
happen okay back back no worries
enjoying hearing the the the old vo
again hearing those characters I would
hope so I mean it's as bad as the
repetitive voice acting is it's also
kind of iconic yeah it really is
stop citizen you violet law cool let's
see this works as well so we finished or
finished we implemented all the magic in
the game last week as well
should be bunch of good there yes the
music still hurt to Skyrim Oblivion's
magic I feel like was way more I don't
know like you could break the game more
you by like combining like spells and
and kind of like making this like really
broken stuff yeah well the the spells as
they were in the game are more or less
the same yeah spell crafting is
something that we experimented with but
we haven't been able to implement it
properly yet remember the same thing
everyone in Al's will suddenly became
invisible
several weeks ago it was sort of fun
first but the note he has definitely
worn off now you can imagine how
difficult it is to run an inn while
invisible once you get a reputation as a
haunted in you can just forget about it
so we've all been keeping quiet hoping
the spell will wear off but we are
running out of patience we're sure it
was anchor tars doing but we can't find
him if you can help us we will be
extremely grateful he's a wizard who
took up residence in the ruins of fort
correcting us a couple of years ago he's
caused us no end of trouble with his
magical experiments but nothing as bad
as this we've tried to find him but had
no luck if he's still living in the fort
he's hiding from us and no wonder if you
could find him and get him to remove
this
first invisibility there we go this this
is one of the many reasons why I just I
love oblivion I mean this this quest
alone I think it's it's kind of simple
when you you know once you've played
through it but the premise I think it's
just so fun yeah just when random mage
setting up shop and and accidentally
turning an entire town invisible I don't
know I wish there was more stuff like
that in Skyrim you can also see oh
there's duplicate gates there's there's
a bunch of invisible goats you can kind
of make out absol everything is
invisible except for the the horses
apparently those are immune that's good
to know
yeah there's something even like the
main quest in this game I I found more
interesting just because you're not the
the chosen one who saves everyone you're
like the guy like a chosen one my both
they're just Indians to be at the right
right I kind of at the wrong place at
the wrong time
yeah and he once he kind of wants to get
out but every time he finishes a quest
whatever he just gets real back in yeah
thanks Brandon with the Emmet can you go
check out the dampers you know bastard
stone to check if he's still doing all
right Sean Bean - oh God forgot there's
a lot of like really famous voice actors
in this on the scam Sean Bean and
Patrick Stewart II the two big ones that
I can think of there is maybe one other
can you guys hear an echo as well right
away
I think might be Sir John Luke and I
haven't been getting audio from the feed
I think I may figure out a way to get
this audio but it's totally fine - if we
can't hear it smoking right now I can
hear it now but I think it's getting an
audio it okay chatter hearing an echo
let us know and we can fix that no I
think I think you're good on your end
Kyle yeah as you can see it works quite
well
why oh really
everyone in town that must have been
what all the shouting was about a few
weeks ago I'm afraid I was engrossed in
an experiment that required my full
attention
you see in order to increase the
efficacy of the spell the radius was
likely to approach the nevermind I don't
need to boy you can see the echo is gone
now well in a year or two maybe a bit
more there's no way to be absolutely
sure that's the exciting thing about
basic research really I find being
invisible but if it will get everyone to
leave me alone fine I did work out a
counterspell last week if I can just put
my hand to it ah here stand in the
centre of town to make sure you get
everyone oh and make sure never mind it
should be fine
yes just read the scroll in the middle
of town it should work although just in
case it might be best if you wore this
ring while you were casting the spell I
make them myself very useful for this
kind of research not that I think
anything will go wrong a serious side
effects are highly unlikely yes if you
don't talk to the guy again and get this
ring you can still do the quests but you
get major deep buffs if you if you use
the spell kind of screws you which is I
mean I kind of know this game in and out
so just that's kind of why I talked him
again
it's it's something you're just gonna
have to experience yourself and an it'll
screw you the first time around with the
second time around you won't make the
same mistake again probably cuz you know
cloud asked question for you is the
original bribe system in this I
completely forgot about the bribe system
I mean nothing is quite like it was it's
it's there in one form or another but
it's not the exact same no oh yeah I
remember that like that weird minigame
where you like have to like go the four
different like yeah things you have to
like click on and yeah that was always a
weird system that you just kind of guess
yeah exactly
your face would react like if they liked
it about but like maybe like so weird
the smiles be like figure that out when
I figure it out I was like oh okay
that's why I'm making this our Thunder
pokes this is so wonderful it is thank
you so much for stopping by and remember
we are doing this for charity so
interested in donating we've you can
head to the link spit ly / - yes - BLM
or fit ly / GS - Co vyd once for black
lives mattered the one the other ones
for kovat relief and if the game crashes
which it hasn't yet yeah I'm gonna
surprise Jean Lee I mean I was only
expecting you to be dead stable
Jean McConville donate $10 for crash
definitely I [ __ ] up I didn't use the
the spell in the right place hard to
believe that anyone could find that too
complicated lucky for you I made a
backup scroll here cheers Mike okay
hopefully works I'm gonna be really said
if it doesn't work because I played this
quest I think like 10 times in the last
two days didn't have a single issue so
of course during the stream it all it
all breaks
I'm not sure where she'd stand though
there may be here please work he only
gives you two Scrolls though I guess I
guess for the people watching I'm gonna
have to redo this quest how much we've
got about 25 minutes oh good call I
wasn't wearing the ring maybe that's it
damn it okay that's enough time never
mind we got this I got this
I'm not an idiot promise our fences
don't worry we know how the des des
Games work
of all the things I was imagining would
go wrong during this dream this wasn't
one of them okay yeah Todd Howard remark
got chat going it just works I mean
that's game development for yeah it just
works until it doesn't and you don't
know why yeah you didn't change anything
since the last time it did work I liked
on our app I think he maybe gets too
much too much [ __ ] but I mean read you
have known saying it just works come on
man yet I've known what you're putting
out in the world another issue I didn't
get the scroll okay there we go
sweet my garlic
I mean usually when I do this quest I
just I stand in like the yeah that's
where a lot of people are gonna hang
here that's how I remember doing it all
right please please please don't make me
look like a bigger idiot thanks okay
okay
know what I'm gonna have to call it
quits I think I'm gonna have to do oh
I'll fix it in my own time like it's
it's a very easy fix I think I know how
but it's it's a bit too much trouble
that's super disappointing okay don't
worry about in that case let's see where
else we can go I mean there's there's
plenty of cool locations on the map we
have like 20 minutes left I think yeah
but ER
are there any requests or should I make
maybe go back to the to the starting
area for the people may have missed it
the first first time city I saw I use
candy gears of candy I think what I was
mentioned he said don't or they said
don't forget the interiors Kyle I don't
know yeah I'm not a professional
streamer everyone okay I just I just I
manage the project that's my job
hey you're doing pretty good yeah
there's a couple people made interiors
but I think we're just gonna have to
reserve that for an update video since
we're a bit short on time there's I mean
that's kind of the problem at this point
in the velum like there's so there's
just so much content already right okay
rest assured for the people watching I
will get this quest working okay I will
do it today I promise you that all this
hype all the build-up for what okay
let's turn off sonic mode see yeah there
we go
Oh actually let's throw in one more show
I spell show me yes do it so I have a
question for for you guys and people in
chat when you play Elder Scrolls games
do you prefer the first person camera
angle the third person or do you kind of
play in a combination of both like it
looks like you like to switch between
well for when I play by myself I'm
always in first person it's just that I
kind of learned because I stream quite a
lot nowadays on Twitch and you know I've
seen these armor sets but a lot of my
viewers haven't which is why I run in
third person out so they can you know
see my character as well yeah this is
more immersive you know totally but this
is more entertaining how are you John
Luke sorry what was the question again I
was the first person or third person he
played Bethesda games a lot of people
who say in first person oh definitely
definitely first person I I never liked
the way third person fell I probably
until like I think like fallout 4 was
maybe the first one that I thought it
was like okay and but even then I think
I just prefer first-person yeah I mean
whenever I'm doing anything important I
always do first person but when I get a
new armor set or whatever or like I
don't know I'm just like yeah my
character yeah cool then I like switch
to third person and just pan around yeah
yeah I think I've missed the third
person more when I like modded games cuz
I would get like those mods for like
Fallout New Vegas I died like bandoliers
or whatever like you know that kind of
stuff
like a potion strap or something for
like oblivion okay this is a really
popular in for Elephants system ignant
go ahead no I'm just gonna say like NPCs
can only go through the door one at a
time which is funny in Skyrim there's
actually a mod very recently that get
released that fixed that only like after
what nine years Wow
it never ceases to amaze me the money
community but LFM says mixed especially
with mods fixing the third-person camera
that's interesting I'd be right to try
some of those out I use first person to
talk to
NPCs but use but use bow pick up items
in 3rd for sword combat I read that
completely wrong mm-hmm I I'm a straight
50/50 camera switcher I always
appreciated that that was an option in
these games even though me to
third-person
especially with this game or with not
this game but with a oblivion
third-person was always kind of janky
yeah I mean that's not the only thing
that was jank and Oblivion to be fair
hey drew you know it's part of the charm
I agree
alright this might be a tough one um
favorite NPC and opal if iam this goes
for chat as well you guys got any
favorite NPCs I'll read them out mine
the BIOS over abayas oh and it's the
grand chair it's gotta be that guy I
mean for me it has to be Martin Septim
that guy's such about us it's like when
I started playing agley vien it was like
in the height of my lord Rings fandom
like it's completely obsessed with
anything more rings and then you have
Sean Bean by your side I just I never
like at some point in the in the main
quest you can have him by your side he
follows you around could you have to
take him somewhere
I just never brought him to
Kluber lu temple i just kept him with me
for like the almost night until was what
would four fifty because I mean there
was no way in how I was gonna get rid of
my free Sean Bean companion yeah I just
loved a guy one of my favorites is I
forget his name but in the Dark
Brotherhood
Sushi's man he's good to the Argonian
who like hates you I think he's an
Argonian
and he's like he's like a total [ __ ]
to you and then there's spoilers there's
a quest where you have to kill everyone
in the brotherhood because there might
be a traitor and then when you go that
when you when you do that quest you go
talk to him and he's like completely
flipped on you he's like you know what I
was being an [ __ ] you're actually
awesome you're my new best friend and
then it's like all right well I gotta
kill you now so funny there's so many
chitchat has a lot of different ones
Hugo Rath I've seen a lot I've seen a
lot of Lucian the chance the wine lady
adoring fan the skooma addict who's in
denial
Rin dear who sells staffs and there's a
lot here I missed a lot a lot of people
saying Martin hands down as well yes
well that's more people in chat mmm-hmm
he only seems great actually um so the
total forgot to mention this before the
the Imperial City Isle has been or is
still being completely revamped as well
the island original living was quite
empty besides from you know the
ginormous city on top of it we added a
lot of farms to it for instance to kind
of supply the city with food this is the
the the waterfront which is where you
know your your ships you know lose their
cargo and and we kind of tried to expand
upon that as well you can see the the
wheel that can take crates up and down
to boards Imperial City
this is also the the poorest area of the
Imperial City technically there's a lot
of four people living in this in this
section of the map so you'll see like
once you're beyond that wall in front of
us
it looks completely different it looks
disgusting which is you know what kind
of going for with this so I think this
came up because you're talking about
Martin following you around someone in
the chat has been asking if there will
be followers in this game I don't
remember if there were followers in the
original yet no not yet you know at some
point that there were people that would
follow you around like the only real
yeah I'm probably gonna get my ass
kicked if I'm not using god mode these
guys don't like if you if you go on the
ship so it's it's not a bog by the way
this is supposed to happen I'm good
the mission tied to that ship I thought
was also pretty good were you like it's
like that boat in and you take a nap and
get up you're in the middle of the ocean
you know it's it's yeah [ __ ] I love
it I mean that that's what we keep
coming back to though like if Oblivion's
quest were so good it's kind of unreal
how and scary it it wasn't bad at all
but everything feels kind of like more
linear it wasn't it wasn't wacky and
completely all over the place it's like
I'm living was yeah yeah as people in
the chat have rightfully pointed out or
corrected me the guy I was thinking of
is a kid not an Argonian it was a mirage
door oh Santa cookie and I was like oh
two pushes for the sheets I guess now
they're correcting me that's the guy in
the dirt Brotherhood who's like a total
[ __ ] to you and then at the last
second he like changes his mind and
likes you I thought we're talk about
mullet was it Malik the liar the Khajiit
oh he's great too oh yeah he's real good
I totally forgot that we didn't show of
black with is the the topic that's kind
of dominated the first 15 minutes how
far the stream we never started though
oh yeah yeah I'd love to see it so
ending for something that's a bit more
clear so we can actually see yeah there
we go
come on
I mean [ __ ] is kind of cool as well I
guess if people don't mind fits the mood
looks great um yes this is uh this is
black wood it's in oblivion in the
original game it was also technically a
swamp it just didn't look anything like
a swamp or a marsh this is maybe one of
the the hardest areas to to make because
it had to be completely demolished and
rebuild but I think it's it paid off big
time against it's so unique there's
there's no area in the game like this
which goes for all the the biomes
technically this week just so completely
different there's just something about
it it's it's ugly but it's it's ugly in
a good wave that makes sense
Oh totally like I love the droopy trees
over the the puddles and ponds and stuff
like that it's it's good stuff that
looks good I like that I like the town
associated with this area too if any
what it's called I feel like yeah there
wasn't like as many quests as I wanted
but I remember like I remember liking
that that town like visually Yaman is
really cool we we actually based our
layin on the Living Concepts as well
like it's great there's really big
bridge so that ships can you know find
their way towards the Imperial City in
the original oblivion it it didn't look
like ships will be able to travel inland
at all which is quite odd I was kind of
sealed off the the the river in the
ocean
we got another another another mean
question here from hahaha ISM probably
that up will the lusty argonian maid be
a new character I mean I wasn't planning
on adding lusty argonian maid
specifically but you know maybe someone
will throw a little Easter egg in there
who knows see questions I can see
better empty sonic speed there's a lot
its lat explorers its claims and it's my
internet you cutting have a little bit
could be my Internet
I was hearing it - oh no okay I think my
computer's is not really appreciating
all the heat and it's gonna suffering oh
what the [ __ ]
he hit me instead the mud crap wait is
he oh it's abandoned okay [ __ ]
I thought it wasn't Imperial Forster we
have another donation you know did you
did you say it while I was gone Jake or
not yet it's not no cool yeah we have a
donation for Kovac relief from lunar
sunlight donate $20 says to the in real
life heroes thank you very much thank
you so much he appreciates in the nation
what we're gonna be going for about
another another 10 minutes here so I
would like to hear some requests from
people like if there's anything you want
to see I mean it's gonna be hard to get
a specific answer in Chad I feel like
mmm but maybe we should try anyway cuz
you know yeah with signal Jayden Hall is
that the town the what other hood is
have you guys like what's that area look
like yeah it's Shane all hasn't been
worked on yet you don't have to show
that then if you haven't worked on too
much I think I think that the best
cities are skinned grad maybe she's skin
right it is really beautiful skin grad
school it's
the bigger towns if I remember it's got
like all the vineyards and stuff yeah
it's it's the one with that big road
that separates both sides of it right
yeah this one I mean we're getting a lot
of fog yeah oh there we go
hello fence says they're good go ahead
no that's good
no no no I love em just says gonna take
so many screenshots with this mod the
world is looking gorgeous oh yeah yeah
that looks great
dang I hope it's it's coming through
alright I think because I'm streaming
this twice technically my computer is
not really enjoying today too much but
should give you a general idea yeah what
this looks like
yeah oh actually we were talking about
favorite quests in oblivion
maybe the the one with glory actually
the conspiracy theory in skin grad yeah
it's crazy yeah I really like that one
that was good cuz he has you follow all
these random people who's like yeah and
then you eventually just figure out like
alright this guy is clearly on something
uh there is a character in this an NPC
in this town I forget if they're like a
shopkeeper and like I'm an apothecary or
something and I'll always remember this
line of dialogue because like you talked
to them and they just start talking
about how like they're asking questions
about if necromancy is illegal in like
Seerat dill and you're like what and
they're just like oh no no reason why
I'm asking or like it's not recommend
its necrophilia that's gave necrophilia
is evil and I remember just being like
what the heck it's like such a random
unique amount of dialogue it's like both
NPCs just kind of have like their
generic lines but I just remember this
one character saying something like that
and I was like oh my god
yeah what's the line yes somebody said
what's the fine for necrophilia oh yeah
oh my god oh there he is
so we got a couple minutes left here if
you got any last minute questions get
him in and we'll try to read them Burn
Notice this name yeah yeah oh yeah this
is a great quest yeah pick end up
murdering all these maybe innocent
people like I love that it's never fully
clear what's going on it's really fun
though I actually well I still have time
I also want to give a shout-out to to be
on scam team mmm we're creating pretty
much all of tamriel like we've been
working together as much as possible to
kind of share assets ideas and resources
and you'll see some of their work in in
our game as well and vice versa
I just really want to thank them as well
and while we still have time I also want
to give a quick special thanks to dark
Odin Zeta X Lorax Arrakis Tiber Lunas
stayed shadow Keller which Wesley Z live
in particular because to really help me
these last couple of days to get this
ready for you guys and of course the
entire sky Bolivian team because that
there's some like insanely talented
people on our team and I mean I'm I have
no doubt I'll see you know some of them
working on some pretty pretty impressive
games in the future so sorry I just I
had to throw it in there no no no please
do absolutely
I got to respond something um anyway
that is all the time we have but thank
you guys so much for tuning in thank you
for all the donations and just watching
this hanging out with us like I said
we're gonna be doing this for the next
two weeks not with sky bolivian
specifically but we're gonna have a
bunch of we've got a bunch of other
stuff planned that you won't want to
miss but thank you so much John Luke fir
for helping me out and joining us and of
course thank you so much Kyle for doing
this and thank you to the team for
getting this prepared this is a huge
treat as a big fan of the project and as
someone who's very excited to see how
this develops and so on it was such a
pleasure having you here it was my
pleasure and I'm sure it was you know my
entire team's pleasure as well I want to
thank the other people for watching and
donating of course and so many people
are excited for the game and yeah thank
you guys for having me over it's it's
really a pretty awesome a unique
opportunity to to be here oh yeah and if
anyone wants to see that quest we kind
of [ __ ] up I'll continue the stream on
my own channels and I know what the
problem is I just have to disable a
plug-in probably so we will get that
working if anyone wants to see how that
kind of ends and unfolds yeah if you're
watching on our Channel and you want to
keep watching more go over to Kyle's you
- not you - well yes youtube as well as
twitch right both yeah I'm life on
YouTube and twitch right now yeah so go
check those out if you want to keep
seeing more but yeah Jake said I think
that's gonna do it for us awesome thanks
guys
[Music]
[Music]